welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is Ryan
Weber probably manager of Google sheets
and today I'll be talking about Google
sheets and giving you some tips and
tricks to boost productivity you can ask
questions at any time on the platform
and we have Googlers standing by to
answer them so with that let's get
started
all right so today we'll be covering
tips to boost productivity that will
span the typical analytical workflow now
the first stage is analytical workflow
is the collect phase this is to get data
from wherever it may live and bring it
right into your spreadsheets next we
have the prepare flow this is where you
get the data in your sheets and you
clean it and get it ready for analysis
turns into the next flow you now analyze
and visualize stage now in this stage
you're taking the data and you're
actually generating those insights and
those learnings to help you know figure
out and make sense of that data finally
we have the share phase this is where
you're sharing out your data in your
spreadsheet in order to get your
collaborators in the spreadsheet to help
you or to share with end recipients will
be viewing and consuming that content
now all this is on top of real-time
collaboration this is at the heart of
not only sheets but of G suite itself
and we'll go into a bit more about how
to get the most out of the collaboration
so that's the order of topics we'll be
going through in today's talk and we'll
end it with I'm talking about how sheets
is ready for enterprise so you can get
the most out of spreadsheets in your
company so that let's dive in let's talk
about getting data into your spreadsheet
so first let's talk about templates so
templates have been added to sheets we
have dozens of professionally designed
templates to choose from the cover wide
variety of use cases and rather than
starting from scratch you can open up a
template and start entering data using
an already crafted template additionally
you can create your own domain templates
the templates that are specific to your
particular company let's say for example
that your finance team has a particular
way like they'd like to
out every month rather than recreating
that report every month in scratch you
can create a template once save it at
the template gallery and that way within
your company that that domain template
is available for you with all the the
themes colors fonts etc that your
company uses already in the spreadsheet
next you can get data into your
spreadsheets by importing it let's say
someone send you a file could be many
different types of files we have support
for CSV for example comma separated
value files and Excel and right from
Gmail
there'll be an attachment card like you
see on the screen and you would simply
click the pencil icon it'll open up that
file into sheets and you can edit right
within sheets of one click very simple
you also can get data into sheets by
import functions so we have a whole host
of import functions that you can use
when you're writing your formulas things
that will pull in data from externally
save files from RSS feeds from webpages
from XML but the one that's used the
most often is the first one the import
range function this allows you to pull
in data from other spreadsheets so you
can write a write a formula that has
import range put in the URL of the other
formula and that will pull in data from
another spreadsheet it's an it's an easy
way to link spreadsheets and pull in
data from other sources so it encourage
you check that out you don't remember
all the information on this slide if you
just start typing equal and start typing
import you'll see autocomplete will show
up along with some information that'll
help you learn a bit more about these
functions Google Forms is another really
popular way to get data into sheets so
with Google Forms
you can simply create a series of
questions of all different types you set
up the form you can send it out to a
bunch of people from whom you want to
collect that information and as they
fill it out and submit that data will
flow right into sheets where you can do
further analysis you can create your
charts your pivot tables and all of that
on that data very simple
next you can get data into sheets via
our API so API is allow third parties to
integrate with sheets so you can get
data both from sheets into third-party
sources as well as from third-party
sources right into sheets and we've
worked hard to continue to update the
API to support all the functionality and
sheets as we add new features we're
continually adding more capabilities
into the API one thing we've added in
the last year is called developer
metadata what that allows developers to
do is to stay on top of how users
interact with sheets so if you have data
within a sheet that's linked to a CRM
system for example and the users in the
sheet are rearranging columns or
renaming things are changing rows the
metadata allows developers to stay on
top of those changes that everything is
still in sync it's like that's a pretty
powerful feature next we're excited to
talk about
SAPT sheets this is a new feature that
launched in the last year now we have
seamless export from s AP into sheets
now we know a lot of companies live on
sa P all the operations they that's
stored there is very critical for
business and so now with very simple you
can export from s AP right into sheets
open up the file in sheets and see all
that all the data and do simple analysis
in sheets if you want check out more
about this you can go to the link on the
screen there google dot cloud.google.com
/ s AP / SI p - + - g suite we're also
excited to announce the sheath data
connectors for bigquery now this is
actually something that we just
announced a month ago at our Google
cloud next conference this is available
today in a beta and what this allows you
to do is connect to bigquery and to pull
in data from bigquery right into sheets
so you can write it write a simple
sequel query in sheets so if you see on
the screen there you can pick your
billing project you hit write query you
can enter in some sequel and then when
you then write your sequel if you hit
insert results it'll now run that query
pull my data and pop it into sheets what
that does now is if you want to refresh
the data I'm going to do is hit the
refresh button and refresh the data for
you automatically you think and share
your collaborators they also can refresh
that data
to the underlying data source no need
for them to write additional sequel
queries it's very simple to have that
connection if you're interested in
trying out this feature in limited beta
go to that link on the screen G Suite to
google.com slash PQ - sheets and sign up
for the beta I'm also excited to talk
about a data connector - Salesforce so
with Salesforce we now have a add-on
that was created by Google cloud in beta
program you can now pull in data from
Salesforce into sheets and you also can
push changes from sheets back into
Salesforce so for those of you who are
interested in that please check that out
alright so that's a few different ways
to get data from wherever it may live
into sheets now I'll talk about
transforming that data and getting it
ready for analysis so in order to prep
your data there's a few things you can
do first we have text to columns so if
you have data that you want to turn into
a table of columns you can use text to
columns feature that we've had support
for that for a while on things like
comma separated values tabs etc so
that's all been there for a while and
you can use that today and we also added
support for what's called fixed width
formatting so if the file on the screen
on the left is an example of a fixed
width formatted file and if you import
it now using text to columns it'll
automatically be turned into the tabular
data on the right so again text to
columns that you can transform raw data
into a table of data if you're preparing
your data for analysis you also might
want to be expanding and collapsing rows
and columns this is a common enterprise
request we've had and we've added in the
last couple of months so now you can you
can easily collapse and expand columns
and rows of these by using this grouping
feature we've also introduced check
boxes into sheets so what check box is
allow you to do is if you have a column
and in that column you have two values
true/false yes/no reviewed unreviewed
whatever it might be you can transform
it into a check box where one value will
be checked and one value will be
unchecked then you can treat the check
box like any other value in sheets so if
you want to use it in a formula you can
if you want to filter on it you can use
a conditional formatting the underlying
value
are still there that just looks like a
Czech glass which we've found users are
really excited about we've also
introduced macros this is a huge
productivity booster it can save you a
lot of time by automating repetitive
work and so what macros are doing is you
hit record and then you can do a bunch
of stuff in sheets
whether it's formatting data creating a
chart whatever you might be doing you
are recording that using the macro
recorder and then when you hit save it
will remember everything you did
so then you can go back and replay that
macro and I'll repeat all the steps for
you that way
you'll save your time and prevent you
from missing a step when you need to
repeat it so it it's a big pro tivity
booster definitely heard you check that
out as well sheets also has recalled
add-on so add-ons are way to add
additional functionality into sheets so
when it comes to data prep they're a
bunch of add-ons that you can use to
enhance your sheets things like removing
duplicates merging data add-ons
normalizing values checking outliers etc
and so all of that again will enhance
your sheets if you add it into your
spreadsheet
there's also add-ons of other types
outside of data prep so things like mail
Market cetera but if you're interested
in sort of supercharging your
spreadsheets definitely check out the
add-ons store and find out some great
add-ons that you can use next I'm
talking about Google Apps Script so
Google Apps trip what is it it's a
scripting language in the Google Apps
platform what can it do and do a bunch
of stuff one you can create amazing so
when you are actually recording a macro
but that's doing underneath the covers
is actually writing those steps in Apps
Script you also can manually do that as
well if you if you want to get more
complex in what you're trying to
automate so you can create as
automations with Apps Script you also
can write custom functions so sheets
gives you over 400 functions
out-of-the-box but let's say you have a
new function that you've come up with
you can you can create it using Apps
Script and then use it like any other
function within your formulas in your
spreadsheets and finally you can use
Apps Script with triggers so triggers
are when there's actions that happen in
sheets so when someone opens a file when
someone makes an edit
to a file all those are triggers then
can kick off some automations you've
created in spreadsheets an absolute
brother so that's another powerful way
to enhance what's possible in your
spreadsheet
so if Apps Script you can see that on
the right it's basically JavaScript with
additional capabilities added to it and
we've worked hard to make it fully
featured and so this year we've added
additional functionality like pivot
tables charts like conditional
formatting among other things into Apps
Script so if you've tried it before give
another shot and see what's possible now
so that I'm gonna jump in to show you a
demo of how to use some of this stuff so
let's let's take a look at a file here
so this file has four tabs each tab is
quarterly data the data is different in
every tab but the columns are all the
same so all the same structure what I
like to do is I like to clean it up I
like to prepare it just once I'll do it
on this q1 tab and then replay those
changes on it in subsequent tabs so to
do that I can go to the Tools menu go to
macros and hit record macro this is
gonna do is now you see a blinking red
light at the bottom so now it's
listening it's recording what I'm gonna
do so every action I take now it will
track those actions and so what I can do
is if I let's say I want to highlight
all of the data in the spreadsheet I can
do that and I want to resize it now to
fit you'll see that next to the red
light it's capturing all of those
actions as I'm recording it so let's add
some alternating colors you can change
it to green let's be done with that and
we also can freeze the first row so
that's easy to scroll and then there's a
bunch of true and false values in that
column
let's see how about let's changes to
percentage and we can fix the precision
to B it looks better and then for the
true and false we can actually just
check boxes rather than saying true and
false so data validation I'll change
this the check box and hit save and so
now that's been changed and then finally
these columns start and finish I want to
hide those columns so I can add a new
grouping feature so let's group columns
G and H and I can collapse this now
so this looks good let's say I'm done
with this I feel like this is a
adequately adequately prepared sheet I
will save it I'll give it a name so here
we can give it whatever name we want to
for easy recall later and then I can
give it a keyboard shortcut in this case
command option shift 1 and we'll hit
save so now it's same in the macro macro
saved great so now if I go to queue to
this tab rather than Reap redoing
everything manually I can go to the
macros menu find that macro and just
replay it and it will do all those steps
for me instantly helps me prevent making
mistakes rent through from missing a
step very simple it's like magic so
that's how macros work all right so
moving on to analyze and visualize so
this is where the rubber meets the road
this is where we are going to discover
all those insights to get the most out
of our data so pivot tables are in
sheets for those of you unfamiliar pivot
tables are a way to summarize your data
to group and aggregate data in useful
ways sheets type to tables for a while
but we worked hard to make them even
better for you this past year so this is
the old pivot table format we've
actually overhauled them to look a
little nicer like you see on the screen
so we think it looks a little a little
better we've added a bunch of other
features as well we now have drill downs
this is ability to to either double
click or say show details on a
particular cell and see all the
underlying values we have groupings so
you can now group up arbitrarily on
values and also expand out in different
ways we have show value as a percentage
there's a common request as well as
being able to customize the text in the
headers you can also choose whether or
not to repeat row labels and I guess I
mentioned before we have the refreshed
UI so all of that has made pivot tables
even better so again encourage you check
that out it's a great great tool in
doing analysis next I want to talk about
different ways to filter data in sheets
sheets actually has several different
ways to do this so first are what are
called filters now filters change
content for everybody so when you filter
down to let's say a particular value
anyone else doing that spreadsheet will
see the same thing they'll all see the
filter data we also have what are called
filter views now filter views when you
filter down to something using a filter
view it's only doing it for you the
viewer it only impacts you anyone else
in that spreadsheet will not see the
changes so that's that's the difference
between that and filters just to really
hit this home you should use filters
when you want to purposely change the
view for everybody viewing the
spreadsheet you want to impact everybody
use filters also any changes you make
while using filters for example changing
the sorting that will impact everybody
even after you remove to the filter now
filter views you should use those when
you don't want to disrupt others views
of the data so if you can if you don't
want people to see what you're doing use
filter views you also can save multiple
filter views in the spreadsheet so let's
say you have multiple different ways of
cutting and slicing and dicing the data
you can use filter views to save all of
those if you want to share a link to
another user with things already pre
filtered you can share a link to a
particular filter view is another useful
way to use filter views and if someone
shares a sheet with you and you don't
have edit access you actually can't use
filters because that kind of changes
underlying data but you can use filter
views because filter views allow even
viewers who don't have edit access to
filter the data so we can definitely
encourage you to check out filter views
if you haven't there like filters but
built for collaboration now sheets has
over 400 spreadsheet functions some of
them listed on the right there we have
everything you can probably think of we
have all the basics if you look up some
if match etc we've also added a bunch in
the last year some of the more
complicated ones we've seen the screen
their statistical functions etc we've
even added functions that are unique to
sheets things like average that weighted
which that's a weighted average and then
we have a new one called sort n which
actually shows you the top n values in a
range so let's go a little deeper on
that one just as an example so let's say
you want to find the top 5 values from
some Salesforce data so in this case I
want to find the top 5 regions by
revenue what I can do so this is the
results that I'd like to see where to
get that is I can use the sort n
function specify the range and say what
top five values and voila the data that
you see above now if I didn't have this
function it would be a lot of work to
make this happen pretty complicated
luckily sword ends there makes it much
simpler for me sheets also has formula
suggestions this is another productivity
booster let's say you're doing some
analysis you have some data you go below
your table of dating you type equals all
of a sudden you'll see some suggestions
of different formulas that you can use
so sheets is predicting what what I
think she will want you can choose one
of those rather than typing things out
manually it's we found that suggestions
have made form entry five times faster
for those who are using it helps speed
things up for you helps prevent you from
making mistakes so if you see those
popping up hopefully you're taking
advantage of those and getting that pro
tip used with formula suggestions next
talk about charts now no analysis is
complete without some charts where we
haven't reads team love love our charts
we have all the basic charts that you
you need we have the pie charts line
charts scatter plots bar charts we've
also introduced a new chart this year
called a waterfall chart see that on the
left there waterfall charts allow you to
see sort of incremental changes between
different segments we've also introduced
a lot of other features to charts in
last year things like total data labels
we gotta go to customize your colors
tight alignment moving data labels
customizing the line styles and we
revamp the chart UI to make it more user
friendly as well so again play around
with charts and see how to get the most
out of visualizing your data next I will
talk about explore so explore is
bringing intelligence into sheets you
can think about it as almost like having
your own personal analyst built right
into sheets
so with Explorer you can ask natural
language questions about your data and
it will give you answers explored will
suggest charts cousin just pivot tables
it can give you formatting suggestions
it's very simple excuse me so on the
bottom right there you see the Explorer
icon you click on that that will open up
the Explorer sidebar again you can click
on the alternating color suggestions you
can ask those natural language questions
very simply
again it's like having an analyst right
within your spreadsheet in the last year
we've continued to enhance with possible
with Explorer now you actually can ask
use natural language to ask for charts
and pivot tables and even if you don't
know to ask for those questions will
actually even suggest pivot tables to
use that's a new feature that we've also
launched the last year so that let's do
a demo so here we have some salesforce
data and we can go down to the explorer
icon click on that to open it up and we
see now this Explorer sidebar is open
so what I can do is I see a bunch of
suggestions here I see some pivot tables
some scatter plots and different charts
let's say I want to ask the question
about my data I can type in this box
here so I want the total revenue by
region and voila I have a pivot table if
I want I also can view this as a chart
as well so I click over here there's the
chart back to the pivot table now you'll
notice that I don't even use the words
pivot table I just say total revenue by
region but yet it knew that a way to
summarize that is to the pivot table so
let's now insert this into your tab
ok great and you'll see that I can
expand this out by date let's choose
closed date and this is added date that
has columns for me and so I see the
individual days here what I want to do
is actually group them by quarter so now
it's going to summarize all those dates
by quarter as my columns against the
regions in the rows so I can see all my
data summarized by both region and
quarter I can click around here and I
notice that in q2
southwest region there's an unusually
high value so I want to dig into a
little bit more I'll right-click go to
show details and now I'm doing a drill
down into the data underlying that five
million rows five million dollars rather
so here you can see all the values in q2
corresponding to the southwest region so
very simple so that is how to use both
Explorer and pivot tables
so that let's jump into the next section
this is share and distribute so again
the reasons to do this are either a you
want to share out two collaborators so
they can help help you refine your
analysis and get more of your data or B
maybe you want to share to your
leadership team or to your managers to
show them all the greatness and results
that you found in sheets so let's talk
about the first use case collaborating
so sheets allows everyone to edit
together seamlessly again real-time
collaborations been there since day one
here you see a bunch of people clicking
around interacting changing values it's
very simple to work together in a
spreadsheet no more sending around
attachments no more worried about
getting locked out of a file or being an
out-of-date file
everyone's will get the right file at
the same time it's very seamless next
let's say you want to distribute your
files by putting them into either slides
or Docs
well now Google supports embedding so
with this you can embed both charts and
tables into both slides and Docs and
when you do that it actually stays
linked to the underlying sheets file so
the cheese file remains the single
source of truth that way if later you
change the data in your spreadsheet you
can go back to your slides and Docs and
one click refresh those charts and
tables very simply rather than getting
out of date or worrying about you know
showing the wrong analysis so again
that's a very simple way to keep data up
to date all within the Google editors
we've also worked hard to help you with
printing we know a lot of you like to
share distributed via via printing and
so we've added a bunch of new features
in the last year things like custom page
breaks custom headers and footers custom
paper sizes print preview custom margins
and saving print settings so all that is
there for those of you like to print
check that out
another huge productivity booster we
find we use all the time here Google in
fact our comments so comments are rich
discussion stock functionality built
right into sheets you can simply click
on a cell add a comment if u plus
mention someone so you put a plus sign
and email
or an app's on an email address it will
autocomplete your contacts name they'll
get an email notification telling them
that they were mentioned in a sheet they
click in that email they'll bring them
right to the file to the to the right
file to the right tab to the right cell
where they can either take action on
this cell directly or they can reply to
the comment itself so you can have a
threaded conversation between you and
your collaborators it's very useful we
also have what are called action items
these are a special kind of comment
where you actually can assign a
particular cell to someone so let's say
you need someone to review a number or
fill out a cell rather than just
possibly mentioning them as an F where
you can say hey Sara can you please you
know to take care of this and so she'll
be assigned that cell so that you know
it'll it'll get done next when you're
clobbering with people sometimes it's
just flow know who has seen that file so
we have now active dashboard another new
feature in sheets so let's say you share
it out with your team it's been a few
days and you're curious okay well who
has actually reviewed it and who hasn't
yet wealth activity dashboard it'll show
you all that and then from this
dashboard you actually can email like
the various people you've collaborated
with so you can find for those who
haven't read it yet and say you know
them from this interface and say hey you
know please take a look I need you know
answers to this by next Tuesday so again
if that is a use case that resonates
with you check out activity dashboard
has something called version history
this is very powerful all edits that are
created in sheets are saved within
sheets and so in version history you can
see who's made changes what have they
changed and when they made those changes
so all that is available to you as an
editor of the spreadsheet we also have
what are called named versions so named
versions actually allow you to save a
name or multiple names to different
important milestones in your
spreadsheets history so let's say you
have a couple different drafts you want
to mark as important milestones or you
have a final version that was a you know
read out to your leadership review you
can keep track of all of that and you
can use this now to actually create
what's called a diff or see what's
changed between adjacent
or milestones that's when the inversions
also check that out
she's also has notification rules so
notification was are useful if you want
to be notified as soon as their edits
being made so let's say you know you
have a bunch of collaborators and you
want to stay on top of when they're
making those edits user notification
rules you can say email me every time a
change is made either when the change
happens or email me a digest or a
summary of all the changes at the end of
the day so yeah this is a more proactive
way of staying on top of all those
changes in your spreadsheet oh great
we've gone through a lot of features
about in the alux workflow we won't talk
now about how sheets is helping users
get even more out of their spreadsheets
for business so one sheets works hard to
keep your data safe and secure no longer
do you need to send around attachments I
could get usually downloaded or put onto
a USB Drive everything is in the files
the require users to authenticate in
fact you can also use two-factor
authentication for even extra added
security also recently announced as
confidential mode in Gmail where the in
the text itself in the email is is
locked down harder to to distribute
beyond that email itself it's harder to
forward copy or print etc so all of that
is working hard to make sure that your
data in your company stays safe and
secure we also have something called
prevent download print and copy so if
you are the owner of a file
you don't want who created that file you
have the ability and the advanced
sharing dialog to check the disable
options to download print and copy
feature now what that will do is for
commenters and viewers they won't be
able to do those items in that file any
longer so it's again it's a way to help
prevent accidental leaking of data
people you know actually printing out
very sensitive file and and having go
beyond where was intended to go you also
can set expirations on sheets files so
let's say you have someone you want to
share with who who only needs a limited
access a limited amount of time what you
can do is you can find that file you can
go to share you can pop in their
person's email address and what you can
do is if you go to the advanced version
the dialog
and you share with them this little
clock put in that clock you can choose
that you want to share with them for
seven days good save that's done is
that's now said that for seven days
we'll have access but the end the
seventh day they'll automatically lose
access to that file again that prevents
them from having access to files that
are more sensitive for a longer time
than you intended
additionally we know that sometimes
folks and business like to like to
travel and so when you're traveling and
you're on a plane with spotty Wi-Fi or
no Wi-Fi at all don't worry she's works
both online and offline so we got your
back will work no matter how good your
Wi-Fi connectivity is speaking of
traveling we also work across your
devices whether you're on your laptop
tablet or mobile we have the sheets
experience there across different
devices that you can stay productive
even on the go finally we know important
keyboard shortcuts are for folks and so
we've we've worked to try and provide
abilities to help transition to sheets
by making easier to to mirror some of
the shortcuts in sheets with those you
might be useful used to in other
programs so there's now a switch switch
that will allow you to override some of
the browser shortcuts that were
originally claimed by browsers like
Chrome and Firefox to now match what you
might be expecting the spreadsheet
behavior to be so if you are someone who
loves their keyboard shortcuts I checked
that out alright so that was a lot of
different tips and tricks there so now
I'm going to do a brief recap I won't
read through all these items here but
going over the high level buckets and we
talked about how to get data into sheets
in all different ways you can you can do
that through importing from your Gmail
using Google Forms through the API etc
we talked a bit about preparing your
data so again this is you can do things
like splitting out your columns and text
to columns you can use macros use Apps
Script etc in the analyze phase we
talked about pivot tables check boxes
charts formulas and using Explorer to
bring intelligence to your sheets and
sharing and distribution we talked about
all the ways you can both share with
your collaborators as well
using things like embedding using
notification rules in version history to
to really get the most out of
collaboration and finally talk a bit
about how sheets is Enterprise ready so
we talked about how you can take
advantage of using links expirations
preventing copy print and download etc
to to really protect your data alright
so that concludes the main part of this
talk stay tuned for live Q&A we'll be
back in a minute
you
all right welcome back we're now gonna
do a couple of questions so let's jump
over to questions from the audience
first question I'm starting to run into
two million cell limit is the sheath
team for planning on raising this I got
good news for you we are so actual we
just announced that we'll be raising it
from 2 million to 5 million cells we
hope that that will help further
increase the the size of the files is
you're able to use today and will be
continuing continue looking at ways in
order to further expand that as well as
making sheets at any level faster and
more performant you know we know it's
important for you to have sheets that
that run quickly and so we're constantly
looking at ways to optimize that so you
so the answer is yes
2 million will come 5 million and we're
also looking other ways to to speed it
up next question are there any plans to
improve charts yes so we've done a lot
with charts in last year I mentioned the
waterfall charts a bunch of other
features that we've added to charts in
last year but we're not stopping there
we're going to continue to to make them
even better
common requests around customization of
charts you know ability to to you know
find fine tune and tweak what's possible
with charts one of things that we're
working on now is actually the ability
to update individual points on or bars
on individual charts so stay tuned for
that that'll that'll be one example of
customization that hopefully make chart
season better for you next question this
presentation showed us a lot about what
you can do in sheets today where she's
headed over the next year - that's a
good question so we've been thinking a
lot about how to further improve what's
possible with analysis and we're
thinking a lot about how to take
advantage of again data lives elsewhere
even especially large data sets and how
you can really analyze that in sheet so
we talked a bit about the bigquery
integration with sheets that's in beta
today that's just the first of what we
hope will be several different features
and functionality and sheets where you
can really do really rich and robust
analysis on your external data sets so
keep an eye out for all that we hope
you're excited as we are about all of
what's possible there
next question what's the best approach
for transitioning from Excel to sheets
have you seen companies do this well
it's a common question that we guess we
know that many of you are coming from
the Excel world and so this can be a
challenge and we admit that but there
you know one thing we recommend is you
don't necessarily have to do it all at
once you can a lot of companies will you
know phase in certain segments of their
company so for example maybe you start
off with you know marketing or sales
it's often easier for them to transition
immediately than then those who use
longer tell functionally in sheets like
the finance team what do we think
everyone can transition into sheets over
time so there's just a matter of them
learning where the things that they they
know and love and excel where that lives
in sheets or so you know again there's a
lot of common misconceptions about oh
she doesn't have this function doesn't
pivottables what we do just be sure to
learn where that is and so there's a lot
of great help content in our learning
center that help provide transition
guides and help users learn how to make
those transitions more seamlessly so
hopefully even your your most you know
stubborn you know finance user will
hopefully find what he or she needs to
do their work and and you can move over
without too much pain last question
what's your favorite spreadsheet
function so I almost said if you look up
that's a great one but I think actually
my favorite is probably the query
functions this is one that I think is
unique to sheets it's very powerful it's
actually you can use a type of sequel
write with from within a formula to do
some really really rich selection and
filtering and querying of your data so
if you haven't seen the query function
definitely try that out I think for you
power users out there you'll really like
what you see I think and with that I
think that concludes today's webinar
thanks so much for your time
you
you